i'm reassured by talking to
eu partners over the last few months
that they don't want to see
uh blockades i think that's very very
important
uh but uh clearly the what matters to
the to us in the uk is we get on with
the rollout of the
vaccine program i think we've now done
over half the adults in
uh in the country which is uh which is
you know very
very good news and uh we're on course to
to do the uh everybody in priority
groups one to four they've been they've
been done but
uh the groups one to nine uh all the
over 50s
by april the 15th and then we'll just
bash on with
the road map that we've set out and with
the with the program that we've got
some suggestion today that we'll be
talking to other eu leaders about this
issue
what would you be saying to them well
i've talked to our friends uh
you know repeatedly over the over the
period we're all facing the same
pandemic we all have the same problems i
think it's one thing that's worth
stressing
is that in on the continent right now
you can see sadly there is a third wave
underway and people in this country
should be under no illusions that
previous
experience has taught us that that when
a wave hits
our friends in it i'm afraid uh washes
up on our shores
as well and i expect that we will we
will feel those effects in
in due course that's why we're getting
on with our vaccination program as
fast as we can but a vaccination
campaign developing vaccines
rolling them out these are international
projects and they require
international cooperation okay briefly
bristol and then the defense review so
just
what did you make of the scenes what
happened in bristol the process
yesterday
well i i think that uh all that kind of
thing is
uh is unacceptable and i think that the
uh people obviously have a right to
to protest in this country but they
should protest
peacefully and legally on the defense
review while we're here today
um how do you justify cuts to the armed
forces in numbers
at the same time as looking to have a
bigger global influence how do you
how do you get that balance if you look
at what we're doing with the
uh the armed forces this is a 14
increase uh in spending on the armed
forces above
uh what was in the manifesto that i was
elected on
in in 2019 it's the biggest uh spend on
uh the armed forces since the end of the
of the cold war
and what it's doing is it's it's it's
enabling us
to modernize our arms services to give
them the kit that they're going to need
for 21st century conflict so making sure
that that we're able to compete in
cyberspace and also
with automated aircraft the future
combat
aircraft system that's being uh made
here in in wharton in
in lancashire and this is a program the
the tempest program alone the future
combat aircraft system
alone that is going to drive 46 000 jobs
overall we're talking about uh driving
400
000 jobs across the the uk 6.6 billion
pounds going into
uh investment in r d so lengthening our
lead as a as a science
superpower as well so i see this as as
vital for
our safety vital for security uh but
also
a massive part of our industrial
strategy and our
our strategy to unite and level up
across the whole country
how do you reassure our allies such as
the us about the
number of the numbers dropping away
though they might be concerned that
we're having
fewer boots on the ground no
redundancies and
uh the if you look at the reserves uh as
well you're talking about a an armed
uh an army of 100 000 and what we're
doing
is giving them the the kit now uh
that they will need to make themselves
all the more uh
useful all the more uh i'm afraid lethal
and effective around the world and are
therefore all the more valuable
uh to our to our allies and and
all the more deterring to our foes and
that's the the name of the game we don't
want to fight
uh wars we want to deter them and we
want to be useful
around the world in partnership with our
friends to keep the peace and
to do that you need strong robust armed
services
of the kind that we're investing in
investing in for the long term
not just for military purposes though
that's absolutely crucial
but for very very good economic reasons
as well
thank you